[موسيقى]
مساء الخير مشاهدي العربيه واهلا بكم الى
التاسعه مع ليلى الاختيار استهلها بابرز
العناوين
بوتين يصف تفجير ساد نوفا كخوفكا بالهمجي
خطط له الغرب ونفذته كييف والتعافي من
الكارثه قد يستغرق عقودا
وزير الخارجيه السعوديه يبحث مع نظيره
الامريكي الشراكه الاستراتيجيه بين واشنطن
والرياض
قبل ساعات من موعد التصويت سجال يرافقه
حراك بين بغداد واربيل لحل الخلاف حول
مشروع موازنه العراق
حرائق كندا تلقي بظلالها على الولايات
المتحده نيويورك اكثر مدن العالم تلوثا في
الهواء حاليا
[موسيقى]
عمل همجي وبربري نفذته كياف لكن التخطيط
كان غربيا هكذا علق الرئيس الروسي
الفلاديمير بوتين على تفجير سد نوفا
كخوفكا بالعمل البربري ذلك خلال اتصال
هاتفي مع نظيره التركي اردوغان
بوتين والغرب بتصعيد الاعمال القتاليه هذا
واظهرت صور جديده حجم الدمار الكبير الذي
تعرضت له المناطق السكنيه جراء تدمير السد
ولم تسلم حتى الحيوانات من الضرر
[موسيقى]
الاتهامات باننا وراء تدمير السد امر
مستحيل فعليا في ذلك الوقت لم يكن جيشنا
ولا مواطننا متواجدين في المنطقه للاسف
الشديد تم احتلال المنطقه منذ مايو الماضي
من قبل الروس لذا فان القول باننا فعلنا
ذلك في وجودهم هو امر سخيف
عقود طويله للتعافي من عواقب وتداعيات
انهيار سد كخوفكا الذي وصفتها كياف باكبر
واسوا كارثه باي من صنع الانسان في اوروبا
منذ عقود لان الخزان اي خزان كخوف كان قلب
احد اكبر انظمه الري في اوروبا ومياه هذا
الخزان ساهمت بزراعه ما يصل الى 80% من
المحاصيل الذراعيه الزراعيه في اوكرانيا
وتجدر الاشاره هنا الى ان السد يعد احد
اكبر السدود من حيث السعه في العالم بنحو
18 كم مكعبا من المياه اذا مشاهدينا
المشهد الكارثي هذا سيخفي معالم الحياه
لدى العديد من القرى بهذه المنطقه
والبلدات على طول نهر النيبرو وايضا اي
ستصبح هذه المناطق غير صالحه للسكن مع
اختفاء الحيوانات والنباتات وفق الجاردين
البريطانيه الخطر ايضا يكمن بالحطام الذي
تحمله المياه المتدفقه وهنالك الحشرات
الالاف من الالغام تدفقت مع مياه الفيضان
عبر خط المواجهه في الحرب هذه مما سيؤدي
طبعا الى تغيير النظم البيئيه في المنطقه
الى الابد لان المياه ستصبح ملوثه بعدما
اختلطت بمواد كيميائيه مثل التسرب النفطي
ومياه الصرف الصحي وغيرها طبعا وهذا الامر
سيؤدي مشاهدينا الى انتشار الاوبئه
والفيروسات والامراض بهذه المناطق ويعيد
تشكيل خريطه اوكرانيا
وموانئها وسبل عيشها وتحديدا بعدما وصلت
المياه من الخزان الى برك التبريد لاكبر
محطه للطاقه النوويه في اوروبا اتحدث هنا
عن محطه زابوريجيا على الرغم طبعا من ان
الخبراء النوويين قالوا حتى الساعه بانه
لا يوجد تهديد فوري هذه طبعا وفقا
للتحذيرات الغربيه
ومن تفجير السد الى خط انابيب الغاز
والامونيا انتقلت الحرب في اوكرانيا حيث
اتهمت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه اوكرانيا
بتفجير جزء من خط انابيب اوديسا الذي ينقل
الاسمده من روسيا الى اوكرانيا في منطقه
مؤكده ان العسكريين الروس لم يصابوا بجروح
[موسيقى]
في حوالي الساعه التاسعه مساء بتوقيت
موسكو فجرت مجموعه استطلاع الاوكرانيه خط
انابيب بتولياتي للامونيا بالقرب من منطقه
خاركيف ونتيجه لهذا العمل الارهابي وقعت
اصابات في صفوف السكان المدنيين وقد تم
تزويدهم بالمساعده الطبيه اللازمه وفي
الوقت الحالي يتم تصريف بقايا الامونيا من
الاراضي الاوكرانيه عبر الاجزاء المتضرره
من خط الانابيب
بدورها اقاله المتحدثه باسم وزاره
الخارجيه الروسيه ماريا زخرفه لان اصلاح
خط انابيب الامونيا الذي تم تفجيره في
منطقه خركافي في اوكرانيا سيستغرق شهرا
واحدا الى ثلاثه اشهر واشارت زخرفه الى
انه تم اخراج احدى محطات الضخم من الخدمه
وتشغيل صمامات الاغلاق
وفقا للمعلومات المتاحه في الخامس من
يونيو تم تفجير خط انابيب الامونيا
في منطقه خاضعه لسيطره اوكرانيا نعم انها
نفس منشاه البنيه التحتيه المدنيه التي تم
ذكرها مرارا وتكرارا كجزء من اتفاق حبوب
البحر الاسود وبسبب استهدافها تم اخراج
احدى محطات الضخ من الخدمه وتشغيل صمامات
الاغلاق ومع ذلك تسربت المواد الخام وفقا
للتقييم الاولي ستستغرق اعمال السياره
والاصلاح لا يقرب من شهر الى ثلاثه اشهر
لنقل الصوره من كافي ينضم الينا الصحافي
محمد البابا محمد يعني بفتره الشتاء
الاخيره كنا نتحدث عن جمود بارض المعركه
بفتره الربيع تحدثنا عن خرق بيبا خموت
وبغيره من الجبهات اليوم مع دخول فصل
الصيف نحن نتحدث عن فوضى على الحدود
الاوكرانيه الروسيه هل يخاف اليوم سكان
كييف من انتقال هذه الفوضى الى الداخل
الاوكراني
مرحبا ليال يعني يمكن القول ان دخول
الفوضى الى الداخل الاوكراني حتى هذه
اللحظه السلطات الاوكرانيه تستطيع السيطره
على كامل المساحات الجغرافيه التي تقع تحت
السيطره السلطات الاوكرانيه يعني الامن
قوات الشرطه والمخابرات والجيش الاوكراني
يقومون بكل واجبهم ولكن نحن الان في صيف
بدايته حار جدا بالكوارث
اكارثه
التي نحن الان يعني في ساعاتها الاولى
وبعد اكثر من 30 او 35 ساعه على هذا
التفجير بدانا نرى معالم كارثه بئيه
وانسانيه كبيره جدا عشرات الالاف من
السكان في مدن المحيطه بنهرب يعني سيبترون
لمغادره تلك المنطقه
لعقود ممكن بسبب تلوث بسبب انتشار الالغام
عشرات الالاف من الالغام اصبحت منتشره في
الحقول والت وحتى بين المنازل ايضا الى
التلوث البيئي والان يعني بالامس ايضا عند
التاسعه مساء تفجير التي اوكرانيا تتهم
روسيا بتفجير امداد خط الامونيا الذي ايضا
يعتبر من المنشات الحياه الحيويه في
اوكرانيا يعني هناك
ضياع هناك حاله فوضى كبيره بين هذا ما
اتحدث عنه فوضى على الحدود الاوكرانيه
الروسيه ممكن ان يدفع الجانب الروسي الى
احداث فوضى مماثله بالداخل الاوكراني
وبالتالي باختصار اليوم ما حدث بموضوع هذا
السد كيف سيؤثر على ان كان الانتاج
الزراعي ان كان كل يعني الصوره الانتاجيه
داخل اوكرانيا
اكثر من 30% من الاراضي الزراعيه
الاوكرانيه ستتاثر سلبيا بسبب هذا يعني
بهذا الفيضان يمكن الفعل وزاره السياسه
الزراعيه اليوم قالت ان اوكرانيا وليست
فقط اوكرانيا وخلفها العالم داخلين على
ازمه كبيره جدا ازمه حبوب لان منطقه
وحتى خرسون تعتبر من المناطق الزراعيه
الاساسيه في اوكرانيا
ستتاثر بشكل كبير لانها تحصل على المياه
العذبه من سد نوفي كحول فلذلك وايضا تلوث
الارض والان للوضع كارثه في تلك المنطقه
يعني يمكن من الان الى ثلاثه او اربعه
سنوات محصول الزراعه في اوكرانيا سيتدنى
كثيرا شكرا لك يا محمد البابا حدثنا منك
في الحرب في اوكرانيا ايضا في وقت تساءل
المراقبون لعده اشهر عن متى واين قد تشون
كلاف هجومها المضاد حدد المحللون
العسكريون لصحيفه تايمز البريطانيه
المناطق المحيطه
باماكن يمكن لاوكرانيا ان تسعى من خلالها
الى قطع الجسر البري الروسي الى شبه جزيره
القرم ما قد يؤدي الى تقسيم قوات موسكو
الى قسمين وعزل تلك الموجوده في الجنوب
الغربي عن خطوط الامداد
هذا وقالت مصادر مطلعه لشبكه ام بي سي
نيوز الامريكيه ان الهجوم الذي استهدف
العاصمه الروسيه الاسبوع الماضي بطائرات
بدون طيار استهدف على ما يبدو مساكن ضباط
ومسؤولين في المخابرات الروسيه فالمتابع
التفاصيل
انها حرب المسيرات بلا شك وكل الساحات في
مرماها وفي المرمى اهداف من العيار الثقيل
شبكه ام بي سي نيوز الامريكيه كشفت ان
هجوم الاسبوع الماضي على موسكو بثماني
مسيرات لم يكن عشوائيا اذ يبدو ان
المسيرات استهدفت مساكن لضباط المخابرات
الروسيه في موسكو بحسب مسؤول امريكي كبير
وموظف بالكونجرس الهجوم هو الثاني في غضون
اسابيع يستهدف عمق العاصمه الروسيه والاول
من نوعه على منطقه سكنيه ففي هجوم
الكرملين بدايه مارس الماضي وهجوم الاسبوع
الاخير ثم رسائل مفخخه تاخذ منحا امنيا
خطيرا يثير تساؤلات حول الاسلحه المستخدمه
لا سيما في ظل الهجمات المتزايده
بالمسيرات خصوصا على مدينه بيلكرود على
الحدود مع اوكرانيا هجمات تشير ربما الى
تطوير كييف برنامجا سريا للطائرات بدون
طيار
النتيجه قادره على التخفي وفق تقرير لشبكه
سي ان ان الامريكيه
اما اول تجربه اوكرانيه سريه ناجحه كانت
لمسيره مداها الف كيلو متر عرضت نهايه
العام الماضي مدى يعطي كييف القدره على
الوصول الى عمق تنكر انها استهدفت سواء
بمسيره محليه او غربيه حصلت عليها من
حلفاء لا يريدون لاسلحتهم ان تستخدم في
عمليه تخريبيه داخل روسيا كما يقولون
[موسيقى]
قد وصلت الخارجيه السعوديه ان الوزير فيصل
بن فرحان بحث في الرياض مع نظيره الامريكي
انطوني بلينكن العلاقات الاستراتيجيه بين
المملكه وواشنطن وسبل تعزيز التعاون
الثنائي الخارجيه الامريكيه اوضحت بدورها
والامير فيصل بن فرحان تعهد بمواصله العمل
لمكافحه الارهاب وتعزيز الاستقرار والامن
وخفض التصعيد في المنطقه كما تعهد بمواصله
التعاون لانهاء القتال في السودان ودعم
الجهود لتحقيق سلام دائم في اليمن
كما اكد الرئيس بايدن خلال زيارته لجده في
العام الماضي فالولايات المتحده باقيه في
المنطقه وسنبقى مستثمرين في شراكاتنا معكم
جميعا من اجل بناء مستقبل مشرق في الشرق
الاوسط وبلا شك فان منطقه الخليج العربي
هي قلب رؤيتنا لشرق اوسط اكثر استقرارا
وامانا وازدهارا واندماجا نحن نعمل معا من
اجل التوصل الى حل للنزاع في اليمن
وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه قال ايضا بان
واشنطن ستواصل الشراكه مع دول المنطقه
مؤكدا ان الولايات المتحده ودول الخليج
لديها موقف متسق تجاه قضايا المنطقه وشدد
على اهميه وحده الاراضي السوريه
وسيادتها
نسعى لايجاد حل سياسي للوضع في سوريا يضمن
وحدتها وسيادتها ويلبي طموحات شعبها
بالتوافق مع القانون الدولي ويمتثل
لقرارات مجلس الامن نحن ايضا ملتزمون بخفض
التوترات بين الفلسطينيين والاسرائيليين
وابقاء افق الامل والعمل على حل الدولتين
وفي السودان واستجابه للازمه الاخيره نحن
نعمل بشكل مستمر على اسكات فوهات البنادق
والضغط لفتح ممرات المساعدات الانسانيه من
اجل مساعده الشعب السوداني على تحقيق
اماله والنقطه التي نركز عليها هي ان
انخراطنا معكم انتم شركائنا في الخليج
التاسعه مستمره مشاهدينا وفيها بعد قليل
معارك طرفي الصراع في السودان تشتد حول
مستودعات الاسلحه والوقود
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد في السودان تجدد القتال
في جنوبي العاصمه الخرطوم في محيط منطقه
الشجره واصطادوين انفجارات عنيفه وتحليق
للطيران في مدينه بحري ووسط العاصمه
الخرطوم هذا ورصدت كاميرا العربيه اطلاق
نار كثيف واعمده تصاعد للدخان ومن
مستودعات طبعا المواد البترونيه الجنوبيه
العاصمه الخرطوم في مقاله مصادر سودانيه
ان الاشتباكات تركزت ايضا حول مجمع صناعي
عسكري يعتقد بانه يحتوي على مخزونات كبيره
من الاسلحه والذخيره في جنوب الخرطوم
معظم القتال في السودان يدور الان في
الخرطوم وفي المنطقه الغربيه من دارفور
يسيطر الجيش على معظم انحاء البلاد بما في
ذلك بورتسودان محللون عناصر من قوات الدعم
السريع تسيطر على معظمي وسط الخرطوم وزاره
الصحه السودانيه تجاوز عدد القتل المدنيين
جراء القتال
865 قتيلا واكثر من خمسه الاف جريح والعدد
الفعلي للقتله قد يكون اعلى بكثير
هذا وقالت قوات الدعم السريع في السودان
بان الجيش قصف سوق بامدرمان قصفه طبعا جوا
مما ادى الى مقتل واصابه عشرات المدنيين
هذا ونشرت قوات الدعم السريع مقاطع لما
تقول انه قصف طيران للجيش لسوق المويلح
فيما لم يصدر الجيش السوداني اي بيان يوضح
تفاصيل هذا الحادث
اما الخارجيه السودانيه فاعلنت بان قوات
الدعم السريع اقتحمت سفارات الصين وفلسطين
ومنزل السفير العماني والفتاه الخارجيه
السودانيه الى ان قوه الدعم السريع سرقت
سيارات دبلوماسيه من السفاره الصينيه
وعبثت بالمستندات كما مارس عناصر التعذيب
ضد
عدد من عمال في مقر السفاره الفلسطينيه
بالاضافه الى اقتحام منزل السفير العماني
بحسب بيان للخارجيه السودانيه
قبل ذلك مشاهدينا قلم متحدث باسم مكتبه
الاتصال التابع للاتحاد الاوروبي بانه لا
يستبعد فرض عقوبات على طرفي الصراع في
السودان في ظل سعي الاتحاد لوقف فوري
لاطلاق النار في البلاد واضاف هنا المتحدث
في تصريحات صحفيه بان اولويات الاتحاد
الاوروبي هي العمل على وقف الانتهاكات في
السودان واشار الى انهم يتابعون طبعا
الوضع عن كثب ويواصلون الضغط للتواصل الى
تسويه سياسيه من خلال الجهود المنسقه من
المجتمع الدولي باسره واضاف ايضا بان تفجر
الاوضاع في ثالث اكبر دوله في افريقيا شيء
لا يمكن تحمله على الصعيد الدولي وان
الاتحاد الاوروبي يحشد اجهزته الدبلوماسيه
بالكامل منذ اليوم الاول للصراع
[موسيقى]
يه 3
روماني
استراتيجي هذا مولع والبنزين كابي حاليا
احنا معه حاليا يحاول نفتح البروفا
عشان نقدر نفضي البنزين من التنك الكابيد
[موسيقى]
وهذه مشاهدينا الصور مباشره الان ننقلها
من الخرطوم للحرائق التي اندلعت جراء
القصف المتبادل بين الجيش وقوات الدعم
السريع وطبعا هذه الصور تظهر بان الحرائق
ما زالت مستمره حتى الساعه وهي اندلعت
بعدد من النقاط هذه النقطه ننقلها الان
مباشره على الهواء
تصويت بالغالبيه ام اتفاق سؤال يطرح ويطرح
نفسه طبعا بقوه عشيه انعقاد البرلمان
العراقي لاقرار الموازنه العامه وسط انباء
متضاربه حول الازمه بين اربيل وبغداد اخر
التطورات تشير الى حذف ثلاث فقرات خلافيه
في تلك الموازنه مع احتمال حسم باقي
النقاط الخلافيه في الساعات القليله
المقبله بين الاكراد من جهه وبغداد من جهه
اخرى في هذا السياق تمت معلومات حتى
الساعه تقول
بالغاء الفقره التي تفرض قطع بغداد
التمويل عن الاقليم خلال 15 يوما في حال
حدث خلاف بين الطرفين حول عائدات النفط
مصادر سياسيه متابعه للقضيه كشفت هنا
لمواقع اخباريه عراقيه عن ضغط يمارسه نور
المالكي زعيم دوله القانون لتحديد الجلسه
حتى من دون الاتفاق مع الاكراد ضغط دفع
المدينه بكثيرين الى التحذير من ان
التجاوز كردستان في التصويت يهدد بتفكك ما
يعرف بتحالف اداره الدوله الحاكم ويزيد
طبعا من توتر العلاقه بين بغداد واربيل
وهنا سياسيون عراقيون وكرد وعرب توقعوا
ايضا امكانيه عقد اقرار جلسه التصويت غدا
الخميس مع استمرار الخلاف بين حكومه اقليم
كردستان وطبعا بغداد حول تعديلات اجرتها
اللجنه الماليه على بعض البنود ومن بين
التعديلات طبعا الزام اقليم كردستان
بتسديد ايراداته النفطيه وغير النفطيه قبل
ان يستلم حصته من الموازنه اضافه طبعا
لالزام الاقليم بايداع ايرادات النفط في
حساب مصرفي بالبنك المركزي العراقي اضافه
الى بنود اخرى من جهاته هنا اكد الحزب
الديمقراطي الكردستاني للعربيه بان الكتله
اي كتله الحزب بالبرلمان ستشارك في جلسه
التصويت على مشروع
ينضم الينا مشاهدينا من بغداد عباس غدير
عضو الهيئه العامه لتيار الحكمه الوطني
ومن اربيل ينضم الينا محمد زين كنا عضو
الحزب الديمقراطي الكردستاني سابدا من معك
استاذ
سابدا من بغداد طبعا مع استاذ عباس استاذ
عباس يعني اليوم هل نحن ذاهبين غدا الى
اتفاق ام الى تمرير البنود الخلافيه وفي
حال كان هناك اتفاق سيكون على اي بنود
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم تحيه لك سيده
الفاضله ومشاهدي قناه العربيه ولضيفك
الكريم يعني واقعه اليوم احنا في الشهر
السادس وانقضت يعني نصف المهله الدستوريه
والسنن الماليه تعرفين اليوم المفروض
الموازنه تكون حاضره على الاعتبار انها
تصيب مصالح المواطن بشكل عام مشاريع
المتنكل مشاريع الجديده الاستثماريه
بالتالي الشعب العراقي ينتظرك على هذا
القانون مجلس النواب يعني حدد يوم الخميس
يوم غد الساعه الواحده ظهرا لتصويت على
فقرات قرار القانون الموازنه بشكل عام
بين الخلافات بين الحكومه وتقليم كردستان
وبعض اعضاء اللجن الماليه لاجروا تعديلات
على هذه القانون
وهذا الخلاف بالاساس ومو خلاف سياسي خلاف
فني تعرفين اليوم اي مبنج او اي ماده
قانونيه داخل هذا القانون يجب ان تتماشوا
مع النصوص ولكن
استاذ البنوك التي نتحدث عنها اتحدث هنا
عن الكميات التصدير عن الحساب وعن غير هذه
البنود كانت بصدد الاتفاق بين الاكراد
اتحدث عن الحزب الحاكم هناك وبين ما يعرف
بالاداره التي حكمت اليوم بالحكومه
الحاليه وبالتالي هو انقلاب سياسي كيف ترى
ذلك استاذ محمد
نعم مساء الخير سيدتي تحيه لكم ولمشاهدين
والزملاء وللضيف العزيز من بغداد طبعا حتى
هذه اللحظه هناك بعض الانباء التي تشير
بان هناك العديد من التوافقات والاتفاقات
التي حصلت من خلال الاجتماعات التي شارك
فيها عن الحزب الديمقراطي الكردستاني
الدكتور فؤاد حسين وهو عضو المكتب السياسي
للحزب الديمقراطي الكردستاني هذه
الاتفاقات يقال بانها كانت ضمن نقطتين
مهمتين اولا اقليم كردستان يعني يجب ان
يصدر يوميا 400 الف برميل نفط باشراف
الشركه النفط العراقيه الوطنيه السومه
والعائدات تكون كلها لاقليم كردستان تعود
لاقليم كردستان فقط رئيس حكومه اقليم
كردستان ليستطيع ان يتحكم بها او من ينوب
عن رئيس حكومه اقليم كردستان بالتوقيعه
ثانيا ان لم يتم هذا التصدير بهذه الاليه
نفس كميه النفط تمنح للمصافي الداخليه
المحليه في العراق والع ائدات تعود الى
حساب اقليم كردستان هذه المساله يقال
بانها حسمت ولكن المفاوضات الحساب البنكي
حسن اجتماع
يقال بانه حسم يعني من حيث بعض الاخبار
التي سمعناها من قبل بعض القنوات الكرديه
وخصوصا قناه كردستان 24 ومراسلها من بغداد
يقال بان هذه المساله حسن التواصل
وبالتالي عادت الحكومه هناك عن التعديلات
اتحدث عن البيندين الاساسيين ثلاثه عشر
و14 13 14 لماذا قامت بهذا التعديل من
الاساس اذا كانت ستعود عنه
نعم السؤال مهم جدا بكل صراحه يعني انا
اتفق مع ما تفضل به السيد
الغدير عندما قال بان هناك اطراف قليله او
اعضاء من اللجنه الماليه مارسوا هذا الضغط
على حكومه اقليم كردستان والحكومه
الاتحاديه من جانب التحليل السياسي انا
ارى بان هناك اطراف تريد تقديم دور حكومه
السوداني هذه المساله مدرجه باتفاق اتفاق
عقد يوم 4/4/2023 بين دوله الرئيس مسرور
بارزاني ودوله الرئيس محمد عشياع السوداني
في بغداد هذه هذا الاتفاق مدرج ضمن قانون
الموازنه وهو اتفاق مؤقت لحين صدور قانون
النفط والغاز او لحين تشريع قانون النفط
والغاز هناك اطراف من داخل اداره الدوله
ومن داخل الاطار التنسيقي بكل صراحه لا
تحدث ان يكون ان تكون للسوداني سلطه
وخصوصا انهم قلقين بوجود موازنه لثلاثه
اعوام وهم ويتخوفون
انتخابات مبكره لذلك هناك هذه ثلاثه هذا
هو السبب الذي اراه يعني
تسبب في هذه النقطه وهذا الانقلاب على
الموازنه اسيا استاذ عباس هذه النقطه
الجوهريه التي تتحدث عن نوايا لدى بعض
يعني الافرقه داخل التحالف
للانقلاب على السوداني او لتقويض حكومه
السوداني ماذا تعني على مسار العمل
بالفتره المقبله وغدا كيف ستنعكس بمجلس
النواب
لا حقيقه هذا الامر غير موجود داخل وقت
الاطار التنسيقي والعلاقه جيده بين السيد
السوداني يعني قيادات الاطار التنسيقي
ومساله اقرار موازي لثلاث سنوات وجاب
الاتفاق مع احزاب والكتل السياسيه داخل
اطار التنسيق يعني اكو اتفاق بين الحكومه
العراقيه
حتى نتخلص من المشاكل اللي دائما كنا
نشاهده بين السلطه التنفيذي وسلطه
التشريعيه تعرفينها كل سنه ميزانيه نتاخر
كثيره في اقراء لذلك ارتات هذه الاطراف
الاتفاق مع السيد السوداني والاحزاب
والكتل السياسه داخل اوروقت يعني اداره
دوله على ان تكون هناك موزه
القضيه الثانيه نسيت اليوم يعني اغلب
الفقرات الداخل هذا القانون هو متفق فيما
بين الكتل السياسيه اللي داخل هذه اداره
الدوله يعني اليوم الثمانيه او 90% مثل ما
تفضل السيد الضيف اكو اتفاق بين الكتل
السياسيه على التمرير هذه البنود والابواب
فبالتالي الخلافات مثل ما ذكرت 13 و14 هو
الخلاف على التسويه الاستحقاقات وتصدير
النفط بين الاقليم وبين الحكومه ولكن حتى
هذه النقاط حتى هذه النقاط كان يشملها
الاتفاق اتفاق تحالف الدوله ومن هنا كان
غير مفهوم موضوع التعديل استاذ محمد ساعود
اليك ايضا هناك من يعتبر بان هذه
التعديلات كانت مدفوعه من بعض الاطراف
يعني بقرب الانتخابات التي ستحصل بالاقليم
هل لهذا الموضوع تاثير ايضا عليها
بالتاكيد يعني هناك علاقه بهذا الموضوع
لان بكل صراحه بعد هذه التعديلات ايضا
حصلت مشكله برلمان كردستان وصدور قرار
المحكمه الاتحاديه بشان عدم قانونيه تمديد
عمر برلمان كردستان نعم بكل صراحه من
المهم جدا ان تكون اطراف ائتلاف اداره
الدوله متماسكه وان يكون الاطار التنسيقي
ايضا متماسكا ولكن بكل صراحه هناك اطراف
ميليشياويه هذه الاطراف الميليشيويه تريد
ان تقدم دور حكومه السودان والا لماذا لم
تتحدث منذ البدايه منذ عقد هذا الاتفاق
وتركت الموضوع الى اخر 24 ساعه من اخر
اجتماع للجنه الماليه وخصوصا انه كان
العدد يعني غير قانوني عندما يكون هناك
عدد غير قانوني في داخل اللجنه برلمانيه
دون علم رئاسه البرلمان وتشضي هذا الموضوع
وتشضي هذه اللجنه واختراقات داخل اللجنه
اذا الموضوع فيه ان نعم المساله تتعلق
بالانتخابات المبكره تتعلق بانتخابات
برلمان كردستان تتعلق الطبع الموجود في في
اقليم كردستان والخلافات بين الاتحاد
الوطني والحزب الديمقراطي الكردستاني هذه
الاطراف نعم كانت مدفوعه لكي تستغلها هذا
الموضوع وتدب الخلافات مره اخرى بين
الاتحاد والحزب الديمقراطي الكردستاني
وتعود المسائل الى نقطه السفر والا بكل
صراحه الماده 62 من الدستور العراقي
الماده
120 121 كلها واضحه محمد تبين سلطات
هذه البنود واضحه بالاتفاق اساسا اسمح لي
ان اخذ تعليق استاذ عباس على ما ذكرته من
محاولات لاحداث هذا الانشقاق عن حزب
الاتحاد الوطني الكردستاني وطبعا الحزب
الحاكم هناك كيف ترد على ذلك
هذه الاختلافات وهذا الرفض لبعض بنود
قانون الموازنه لم ياتي فقط من بعض الكتل
داخل اطار التنسيق يعترف 15 عضو داخل هذه
ما جاء بالقانون مع التعديلات واغلب
الاحزاب الكرديه مثل الاتحاد والجيل
الجديد وباقي الاحزاب هي مع تعديلات
اللجنه الماليه فبالتالي هذا ما محصور فقط
باطراف الاطار
فبالتالي اليوم اي قرار وحتى الاتفاقات
اللي يصير داخل ائتلاف اداره الدوله يذيل
في كل اتفاق انه اي اتفاق واي بند متفق
بالحكومه العراقيه وبالحكومه تقلب كردستان
وبين ما يكون داخل البرلمان يزيل في ذيل
القائمه على ان يكون متماشي مع النصوص
الدستوريه فبالتالي اي قانون واي بند واي
ماده القانون القانون الموازنه لا يتماشى
مع الدستور العراقي سيرفظ من اللجنه
الماليه وكل اطراف الاداره الدوله ولكن ما
يتحدث عنه محمد هو
ان تاكل الاتفاق السياسي يعني الانقضاض
على باقي المواد
والمتفق عليها بين الطرفين شكرا لك من
بغداد عباس غدير عضو الهيئه العامه لتيار
الحكمه الوطني ومن اربيل محمد زين كان عضو
الحزب الديمقراطي الكردستاني شكرا لكم
وقعت الخطوط الجويه البريطانيه وهيئه
الاذاعه البريطانيه بي بي سي وشركه بوتس
وقعت الاسنادان ضحيه قراصنه روس تطلق على
نفسها اسم كلا ونتج عن عمليه القرصنه سرقه
بيانات رسميه لاكثر من 100 الف موظف هذا
وطالب المقرصنون بفديه ماليه مقابل رد
البيانات قبل الرابع عشر من يوليو وفي حال
عدم دفع الفديه هدد القراصنه بنشر بيانات
الموظفين على الانترنت بما فيها طبعا
تفاصيل حساباتهم المصرفيه وهنا اكد المركز
الوطني للامن السيبراني بانه يعمل بدقه
لمعرفه ملابسات عمليات القرصنه وتاثيرها
على المملكه بشكل عام
[موسيقى]
اعلنت الحكومه البريطانيه انها تعتزم
ازاله جميع معدات المراقبه التي تصنعها
الشركات الصينيه من مواقعها الحساسه وذلك
في محاوله للحد من الجمع المحتمل
للمعلومات الاستخباراتيه من قبل بكين وفقا
طبعا للتحذير البريطاني الذي اكد بان
السلطات ملتزمه بنشر جدول زمني لازاله
معدات المراقبه التي تنتجها الشركات
الخاضعه لقانون الاستخبارات الوطنيه
الصيني من مواقع الحكومه المركزيه الحساسه
في المملكه المتحده واضافت لندن بان هذه
الاجراءات الجديده ستحمل قطاعات الحساسه
من الشركات التي يمكن ان تهدد الامن
القومي
ينضم الينا مشاهدينا من لندن مصطفى زارو
مراسل العربيه مصطفى يعني عندما نتحدث عن
البدء بازاله هذه الكاميرات ما هي المهله
الزمنيه الموضوعه وكيف يعني ستتم عمليه
ازاله كل هذه الكاميرا
حقيقه ان الحكومه يعني بدات بازاله هذه
الكاميرات من دوائرها الحكوميه ولكن في
بعض القطاعات ولا سيما بعض الاقسام
التابعه لوزاره لا تزال بها هذه الكاميرات
وتحث الحكومه الان هذه الاقسام بالتسريع
بالتخلص منها قبل يعني موعد تحديثها
وبالتالي هذه رساله قويه تقول الحكومه
بانه اجراء
ليظهر النهج الاستباقي للحكومه لمحاوله
وقف كل من يحاول تهديد البلد من خلال
منتجات وربما يتم استخدامها لتقويض
الحكومه والمجتمع واليوم نشرت الحكومه
بيانا حول حول هذه الاجراءات اولا
لحمايه الامن القومي البريطاني ولاول مره
يتم انشاء وحده معنيه
الامن القومي بل ايضا وهو يفتح مجالات
لشركات صغيره وخاصه في ان ان الحكومه الان
تريد ان تتخلص من بعض قوانين
الاتحاد الاوروبي ولهذا تم يعني سيتم
التعامل او درس او مناقشه هذا القانون
الاسبوع المقبل في البرلمان شكرا لك مصطفى
مراسل العربيه حدثتنا من لندن
مشاهدينا سانتقل واياكم الى هذه الصور
المباشره للحرائق في حرائق الغابات طبعا
في كندا واثارها على مدينه نيويورك
الامريكيه كما نشاهد بوسط نيويورك كيف
السماء يعني حمراء الرؤيه صعبه هناك وطبعا
تم تحذير السكان بعدم الخروج الا في حاله
الضروره نظرا لان مستويات جوده الهواء في
نيويورك وصلت الى يعني ادنى مستوياتها
ووفقا للمواقع المعنيه بالمناخ تقول بان
رداءه الهواء تعتبر بانها الاعلى عالميا
حتى سنعود مشاهدينا الى هذا الموضوع لسياق
النشره والى مراسلينا بنيويورك وايضا
بكندا التاسعه مستمره وفيها بعد قليل
نائب ترامب يتحداه رسميا مايك بانسي يعلن
ترشحه للانتخابات الرئاسيه في الولايات
المتحده
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد اخلت مشاهدينا السلطات
الكنديه اكبر مقاطعه واكبر مدينه في
مقاطعه
شماليه البلاد وهذا ويعمل رجال الاطفاء
على مكافحه 150 حريقه في الغابات من بينها
اكثر من 110 حرائق صنفت خارج عن السيطره
وحذرت السلطات السكان المعرضين للخطر
بمناطق شماليه وشماليه غربيه في مقاطعه
كبك بضروره البقاء داخل منازلها
اذا مشاهدينا هذه الصور المباشره من من
نيويورك من الولايات المتحده
للتلوث الذي نتج عن
الحرائق المشتعله في كندا والتي طبعا هي
حرائق غير مسبوقه وصنفت بانها الاكبر منذ
اعوام
وطبعا هناك العديد منها خارج عن السيطره
ساذكر مشاهدينا بان بلغ بانه قد بلغ مؤشر
جوده الهواء في نيويورك 167 درجه وهو رقم
كبير جدا قياسا
للمؤشرات العاديه هو ما يشير طبعا الى
ارتفاع التلوث الى مستويات خطيره تؤثر على
صحه الانسان اذا قررت اداره الطيران
الفيدرالي الامريكي توقيف رحلات جويه الى
مدينه نيويورك بسبب ضعف الرؤيه الناتج عن
حرائق الغابات وقالت اداره طيران ان
الرحلات الجويه المتجهه الى مطار نيويورك
اما توقفت مؤقتا او تاخرت عن موعد وصولها
فيما غطى دخان الحرائق سمك سماء نيويورك
ومبدا الامم المتحده وهذه مشاهدينا صور
مباشره لمطار نيويورك حيث ايضا غطى الدخان
كل المدرجات وكل سماء المطار مما يؤثر
ومما يؤثر على حركه الملاحه الجويه
اذا مشاهدينا اعيد بان هذه الصور المباشره
لمطار نيويورك والتي تظهر ايضا بان السماء
حمراء وهناك صعوبه طبعا للخروج وصعوبه
لتسيير الملاحه الجويه مما دفع بالسلطات
هناك الى ايقاف الحركه الجويه بعد بعدما
يعني
تاثرت مدينه نيويورك بشكل كبير بالحرائق
التي اندلعت في كندا ووصلت مستويات التلوث
بهذه المدينه الى مستويات غير مسبوقه تؤثر
على صحه الانسان طبعا وبحسب الاداره هناك
فان الجسيمات الدقيقه مشاهدينا الموجوده
في الهواء هي من بين الاكثر اكثر الجسيمات
ضررا على صحه الانسان وعلى
الانسان الذي يعاني من امراض الجهاز
التنفسي ومن امراض قلب وبالتالي هنا نصحت
السلطات المعنيه المواطنين بعدم الخروج
وبعدم التعرض للهواء الا في حال الضروره
طبعا وفقا طبعا لوسائل اعلام امريكيه فان
مدينه نيويورك عاده تستوعب في المتوسط
مشاهدينا بين 35 ميكرو جراما من الجسيمات
الدقيقه لكل متر مكعب من الهواء يوميا وقد
ارتفع هذا العدد مع او هذا الرقم مع
اندلاع الحرائق في كندا الى 140 وصولا الى
160 ومن المتوقع بحسب التقارير هناك ان
يصل الى
335 الليله
بسبب حرائق كندا نيويورك تسجل اسوا تلوث
للهواء في العالم والخروج الى الهواء
الطلق ممنوع الا للضروره المطلقه بحسب
طبعا سلطات المدينه الامريكيه بعدما هب
مشاهدينا دخان دار جنوبا من اكثر من 100
حريق اتحدث هنا عن حرائق غابات مشتعله في
مدينه كبك بكندا ليسجل مؤشر جوده الهواء
في نيويورك اعلى من 200 عند نقطه محدده
ليله امس وهو مستوى غير صحي نهائيا في وقت
لاحق سجلت نيويورك ثاني اسوا مستويات تلوث
للهواء في العالم بعد ان يدلهي في الهند
ومن المدن الاخرى على القائمه كمدينه
بغداد في العراق وايضا له في باكستان
حفاظا على الامن الصحفي المدينه
الغت عشر مناطق تعليميه على الاقل في وسط
ولايه نيويورك الانشطه والفعاليات
الخارجيه ومن المتوقع ان يبقى الدخان في
المدينه الى اليومين المق وفي طلب كذلك
الذين امروا به عند انتشار كورونا طالبت
السلطات السكان بارتداء الاقنعه العاليه
الجوده مثل الان نانتي 5 والكيو ان 95
ايضا في حال الخروج الى الهواء الطلق يجب
ارتداء هذه الاقنعه كما اجتاح مشاهدينا
الدخان المنبعث من حرائق كندا بشكل دوري
شمال شرقي ووسط المحيط الاطلسي لاكثر من
اسبوع مما اثار مخاوف بشان اضرار استمرار
داءت نوعيه الهواء هذا وكان اندلاع اكثر
من 400 حريق ضخم في جميع انحاء كبك ودمرت
هذه الحرائق في كندا ما يقارب التسعه
ملايين فدان هذا العام مع حرق ما يقارب
ايضا من نصف مليون فدان في كبك وحدها
[موسيقى]
ينضم الينا مشاهدينا طلال الحاج مدير مكتب
العربيه في نيويورك وايضا من تورنتو رفاه
سعد مراسلات العربيه ومن واشنطن ريتا
سليمان مراسله العربيه سابدا مع زميل طلال
الحاج طلال كيف هي الصوره من يعني الوضع
سيء جدا بحسب الصور المباشره التي نتابعها
من هناك وما هي الاجراءات التي تتخذها
السلطات
بالفعل الصوره قادمه اللون الاحمر يسود
على الجو وهذا من يوم امس الثلاثاء في
واقع الامر وسيستمر حتى منتصف الليل على
اقل تقدير وربما السماء استمر ليوم او
يومين اخرين حسب اتجاه الرياح القادمه من
كندا الى الجنوب اذا تغيرت اتجاه الرياح
يمكن ان تخف هذه المشكله في صعوبتها هنا
في نيويورك طبعا هي سحب دخانيه مكونه من
جزيئات صغيره من الكربون قد يستنشق
الانسان الى رئته وفق الاطباء تدخل مجلس
دم ويعاني كلبا من اثارها وخاصه اولئك
الذين يعانون من مرض الربا او الربي او
الازمه ولذلك لذلك نصحت الحكومه المحليه
وعمده المدينه صباح اليوم في مؤتمر الصحفي
بان يرتدي المواطنون المدينه
اقنعت الواجهه لمنع تناشي قضيه الجزيئات
ويشاهد الان مناظر تذكرنا بعام 2020 وهم
يلبسون لكن على الطبيه الواقيه كما كانوا
يلبسونها ايام الانتشار
الكوفي المدارس الثلاثي وقت ما زالت
مفتوحه كما تفضلت في ليال ولكن جميع
النشاطات الخارجيه خارج الفصول تم الغائها
وما زال العمل ساريا في اليوم المتحده
وكذلك في بورصه نيوكلا العالميه على قدم
وثاق ولكن هناك نصيحه لمعظم العاملين
سانتقل الى واشنطن الان والزميلا سليمان
ريتا ايضا هل ممكن ان ننقل الصوره من هناك
لو سمحتي
طبعا كما تشاهدين
دعيني اخرج من اطار الكاميرا
الضباب يلف مدينه واشنطن الان
معالم المدينه بدات تختفي تدريجيا
وايضا رائحه الدخان معباه في الهواء لا
نستطيع ان نتنفس بشكل طبيعي وايضا دعيني
اشير بانه حركه السير في المدينه ليست على
طبيعتها في مثل هذا الوقت من
النهار العمل يوم العمل طبعا ايضا
المستشفيات متاهبه للتعامل مع ازمات
التنفس خاصه مع من يعانون من الربو وامراض
القلب
يعني
ابلغت الناس بعدم الخروج كلا
حتى الان السلطات لم تمنع المواطنين من
الخروج من منازلهم ولكن من المتوقع ان
تسوء جوده الهواء يوم غد اليوم مؤشر
الهواء نسبه جوده الهواء في واشنطن بلغت
176 هو رقم عال ولكن من المتوقع غدا ان
يرتفع بظل استمرار حاله الطقس واستمرار
الرياح على ما هي عليه
وحدها الرياح يمكن ان تزيح هذه الازمه
دعيني اشير ليال بانه ولايه بنسلفانيا
المجاوره تم اعلان بعض المناطق فيها تحت
المؤشر الاحمر وهو مؤشر خطير جدا تماما
مثل المؤشر في نيويورك ساعود اليك ريتا
اسمحي لي ان انتقل الى رفاهه من كندا
للنقل الصوره رفاه يعني العديد من الحرائق
هناك خرجت عن السيطره حرائقين مسبوقه
وهناك مطالبه لدعم دولي للمساعده باخماد
هذه الحرائق كيف هي الصوره من هناك وهل
ستسوق بالساعات المقبله
بحسب البيئه الكنديه والصحه ايضا قالت ان
هذا الصيف صيف عام 2023 هو الاسوا في
تاريخ كندا من ناحيه ارتفاع درجه الحراره
والجفاف وزياده الحرائق في الغابات
الحرائق مستمره مثل ما تعلمين لذلك
تحذيرات بسبب تلوث البيئه وتلوث الهواء
الذي وصل الى نسبه الخطوره استنشاقه وصل
الى نسبه الخطوره على حياه الاشخاص خاصه
ممن لديهم امراض تنفس امراض القلب طبعا
اليوم وصلت رسائل الكترونيه الى اولياء
امور في مدينه تورنتو وايضا المدن التي
حولها من انه الغيت جميع النشاطات
المدرسيه التي تكون في الخارج ايضا الغي
يوم الركض العالمي الغيت بعض الانشطه
الرياضيه الموجوده في الخارج حضرت السلطات
الناس من عدم الخروج الا للحالات الضروره
طبعا مثلما تشاهدين من الخلف يبدو ان
اللون اللي كان الاصفر او الاحمر بدا
قليلا فالشمس تحاول ان تخترق
الغيوم اللي كانت ملبده بالدخان الاسود
اليوم شهد اختلافا قليل مهما كان لكن
التحذيرات من تلوث الهواء لازلت مستمره
نتحدث نعم
اسمحي لي ان اعود الى
تحذيرات من تلوث الهواء اليوم هناك تحذير
لاكثر من 30 مليون امريكا حول موضوع يعني
التلوث الموجود بالهواء وهناك بعض
الولايات التي من المتوقع بساعات الليل ان
تسوء الاوضاع فيها عن اي ولايات نتحدث وما
هي الاجراءات المتخذه حتى الساعه
من المتوقع طبعا ان تزداد
جوده سوءا جوده الهواء سوءا في الولايات
ولايه فرجينيا وولايه ميريلاند طبعا ميري
لاند المتاخمه لبنسلفانيا التي كما ذكرت
سابقا بانه تم اعلان بعض المناطق فيها تحت
المستوى الاحمر ولايه فيرجينيا وايضا
كارولينا الكان ولايه كارولينا الشماليه
وحتى كارولينا الجنوبيه هذه المناطق
الواقعه في الشمال الشرقي للولايات
المتحده كلها تقع تحت تاثير هذه الحرائق
وهذا الهواء الاجراءات التي تم اتخاذها
حتى اللحظه هي اجراءات طبيعيه حتى اللحظه
مصحه تعبير المدارس هنا مستمره لم يتم
الاعلان عن اي عطل في الغد ولكن تم انهاء
جميع
الدروس والحصص
التعليميه رحلات الخارجيه في الجامعه
وايضا الجامعات ايضا هذا الواقع ولكنها
مستمره
شكرا سليمان اعود اليك رفاه قبل ان اختم
اليوم الدعم الدولي لكندا كيف هي الصوره
يعني بالساعات الماضيه وما المتوقع بساعات
المقبله
نعم بالفعل وصلت قوات متعدده جنسيات خاصه
الى مقاطعه فمثلا فرنسا ارسلت 100 من
قواتها لدعم رجال الاطفاء في كبك وايضا
بالاضافه الى الجيش الكندي طبعا الذي وصل
منذ ايام مثل ما تعلمين ان الحرائق مشتعله
في اكثر من 100 غابه كلها هذه خارجه عن
السيطره هناك الاف النازحين عن هذه
المناطق مثلما تشاهدين خلفي ليال انا
تقصدت اليوم ان اقف في احدى الغابات هذه
الغابات في كندا انها غابات كبيره وفيها
ايضا اشجار ضخمه وكبيره وخشب فعندما يندلع
حريق واحد في واحده من هذه الغابات ينتشر
بسهوله خاصه بسرعه الرياح التي يشهدها في
الايام بدات رفاه سنبقى نتابع نقل الصوره
معك مع الزملاء بالنشرات اللاحقه شكرا لك
رفاه السعد مراسله العربيه من كندا وريتا
سليمان مراسلات العربيه من واشنطن شكرا
لكمما
نائب الرئيس منافسا للرئيس هي سابقه في
السياسه الامريكيه الحديثه مع تقديم مايك
بانس اوراق ترشحه للانتخابات الرئاسيه وهو
الذي شغل منصب نائب الرئيس السابق دانيل
ترامب لكن ما الذي يحتاجه بانس للتفوق على
ترامب في سباق الجمهوريين نحو الرئاسه
طريق الرجل على ما يبدو ضيق نحو البيت
الابيض وللنجاح بمحاولته للوصول الى
السباق الرئاسي سيحتاج الى تعثر ترامب
والتركيز على ميزه لديه قد تجعله يتفوق
على رئيسه السابق لانه كرجل متزين يتمتع
السياسي القادم بولايه انديانا بتاريخ
طويل من العلاقات الوثيقه مع مجتمعه
المحافظ وهنا كان قد هذه احد اسباب اختيار
ترامبلي بانس ليكون شريك في انتخابات عام
2016 لكن مشاهدينا لانه طبعا يخفف من حده
مخاوف الناخبين المتدينين الذين قد
يترددون في دعم ترامب القادم من نيويورك
والمتزوج ثلاث مرات ولديه قضايا شخصيه
واشكالات كثيره كما نعلم وهو يامل الان اي
بانس من الاستفاده من ذلك التاريخ
الاستقطاب الناخبين المتحفظين للرئيس
السابق طبعا للتصويت لصالحه ورغم ذلك
مشاهدينا سيواجه بانس هذا التحدي مع
مرشحين اخرين يتنافسون ايضا على ذات
الاصول ومن بين هؤلاء المرشحين راندي
سنتوس الذي دافع عن القضايا الثقافيه
المحافظه في فلوريدا تحديدا
[موسيقى]
ختام التاسع مشاهدينا مع العناوين
بوتين يصف تفجير سد نوفا تخوفك بالهمشي
خطط له الغرب ونفذته كييف والتعافي من
الكارثه قد يستغرق عقودا
وزير الخارجيه السعوديه يبحث مع نظيره
الامريكي شارك الاستراتيجيه بين واشنطن
والرياض
[موسيقى]
قبل ساعات من موعد التصويت سجال يرافقه
حراك بين بغداد واربيل لحل الخلاف حول
مشروع موازنه العراق
حراق كندا تلقي بظلالها على الولايات
المتحده نيويورك اكثر المدن واكثر مدن
العالم تلوثا في الهواء حاليا
مشاهدينا الى هنا اتي الى ختام التاسعه
شكرا لحسن المتابعه والى اللقاء والان الى
360 والزميله راويه مساء الخير راويه ماذا
لديك مساء الخير ليان طبعا سنكون بمتابعه
للحرائق المندلعه في كندا وتاثيرها على
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه وايضا استمرار
تبادل الاتهامات بين روسيا وايضا اوكرانيا
تفضلي
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات